when I realized when I came out of
prison when I went first of all when I
get started
it wasn't violent we were all
businessmen
my godfather who I believe started I
would be the buy the lead person that
would have been the original if you want
to say cartel head he would told me if
you got a carry a gun to do business
with someone you have no business doing
being with that person right so we
didn't you know we can't carry gun we
didn't do anything we're business people
I mean he own construction company hyung
the largest coal mines in Colombia the
largest emerald mines I mean very well
Airlines very wealthy people so when
when I realized I come out of prison I
go in in 79 I come out in 85 and I
realized it was in the world that it was
you know my clients 80% of our the coke
they were bringing in was going to
California
my client was 80 percent yeah my clients
were the high Society of America they
were the movie stars that was a musician
the real famous names everybody knows so
I come out and all sudden there's a
thing called crack which I didn't agree
with number two there's people killing
each other and I was still I went back
for two more years and then I realized
that this is just a me so for me then
it's just like if you have a company
that that manufactures his water and
doesn't sell or you don't like the water
anymore
you stopped selling it you shift and you
go to another business right yeah so for
me was easy I went back to building my
orange groves you know what the number
one horse breeder in America I had the
best stud in the world and I could do
that transition no problem at all
difficult to give up the power the money
I have more money they could ever spend
the rest of my life I walked away when I
was 31 years old and I had everything
but they can't why because their
identity is a drug dealer so you take
like like you see ballplayers today why
can't they just go out in the height of
their career why they get traded and
they still want to play because they
don't know nothing else but to be a
ballplayer you know like I told Johnson
also one time and I said to him I said
what are you
is it a ball player said really I said
John what happens the day you came to a
hundred-mile-an-hour fastball I said to
me you're a child of God given a
tremendous gift to make millions playing
a game right so that's why you see all
these people that they can't you know I
next dose an instant I almost think that
it becomes a game for them that the
payoff is getting caught mm-hmm you know
and and you seen it over and over again
with all of them because at the end of
the day how much money can you spend how
many cars change Drive
how many mansions can you have you know
when you got except out of millions of
dollars you can live the rest of your
life super comfortably I mean you can't
go to strip joints and blow a hundred
thousand dollars a month right but you
know that's in dust and that was the
thing so I walked away and when I walked
away and originally I thought my life
would be in danger I hired this guy to
teach me karate I'd done karate for a
lot of years and the first day he came
he said I'm gonna teach you about the
sword man and I was so excited
right I mean I had a I love weapons and
I'm like man we never waste time
throwing kicks and punches I've done
that well he does run shows me a Bible
and I was so pissed because I was a
hardcore atheist I'm like dude first of
all I'm paying you a lot of money I
don't believe in that book what the book
talks about so tomorrow you leave that
[ __ ] sword home and bring the real
sword and here's a guy was a seven
degree black belt and got up in my face
first person that had the guts to get up
with my face and he like young man what
I got to give you you got no money to
pay I said to myself man this guy's
seven degree black belt I breathe behind
my back and I have a gun said this guy's
gonna introduce Jesus into me I was pay
for it I said dude don't get excited
while the steam room is heating up waste
your time you know and for three years
and people say what did he say that made
you change your life and I said really
nothing because for two hours of getting
my ass whupped I was just getting what
waiting for him to while he was reading
the Bible to me I was just getting over
the last weapon giving me for two hours
yeah so
but it was everything he did he lived in
what I call a very crappy world right I
mean I lived in this 10,000 square foot
house 15,000 my guesthouse was 5,000
square feet his house was 1,200 square
feet you know he drove up be all beat up
car had milling out with the cars and
then he's tell me how madly in love he
is with this woman there he's been
married to for 25 years so I'm like 25
years she was reading her 40s man how
can be I mean I'm surrounded by
supermodels and I hate him and he's in
love with this I'm like man is this
lady's gotta be like I mean so much [ __ ]
I gotta go check her out
and when I saw her I thought the guy was
sick and I'm like it's impossible and
the thing about nowadays she's gorgeous
she's a great person I love them to that
but in my world the you know there was
identified them gave value to your life
he had none of them so why would he be
happy not miserable you know and and I
kept asking him and he never invited me
to church or anything like that he gave
me a really neat answer which is part of
what I do today and his answer was you
know I have an intimate relationship
with Jesus and I'm like what I said
first of all you know you don't know the
guy fist
how can you undo relationship with
someone donation I'm surrounded by
people that die for me and I don't have
intimate relationship with them you
don't have time for ancient myths right
yeah I mean dude how do you exist he
said well I know Eric cyst and I can't
see it so I'm like and that's what he
would say and really what I wanted him
to say to me well like oh yeah I want
him to battle me because I could fight
that I could do but I couldn't find
someone they wanna fight back and and
for three years he didn't waver didn't
waver and I never forget it was July 1st
1990 10:30 in the morning my divorce was
final from my ex-wife and I saw her
dragging away my little girl which was
everything my life the reason how was
the main reason why I finally walked
away from this world and man I went to
and I saw her crying I went to my room I
got on my knees and I'm like I can
remember that till today I said first
and foremost Jesus
believe you real that's how I want to be
I want to be honest I'm honest you know
number two if you're real you're
probably get me said you're so bad you
stay down there and I'll stay up here
number three but if you are the recent
no man is happy and you changed his life
change your mind I'll die for you
you know and uh Christians say that when
someone converts there's angels and
everyone like I'm CUBAN they must not be
able to play to the Cubans riding a [ __ ]
you know yeah I'm light and actually in
three month my life was from bad to
horrific ly worst I get arrested I was
at a horse show and no clue why I was
arrested when they bring me in on this
conspiracy my attorney says don't worry
you're gonna go home the only pilot the
only person testifying against you it's
a pilot and he died he killed himself in
using a DA airplane to smuggle in the
fog in Alabama and he says they don't
have anything issue it was a conspiracy
160 people and they had all been
indicted and their head guy had gotten
life and he I knew and he had
transported for me years ago way past
the statute of limitation which is five
years but uh he's like just plead
innocent and we're gonna go home mm-hmm
and I looked at him and I'm like Alan
I've been in my attorney forever one of
the top drug lawyers in the world
I said Alan here's the deal man here you
are a good Jew that I know and love tell
me going home you know I give him my
life to show you that ain't said nothing
to be yet but I know one thing if my
life is gonna change I gotta change I
can't continue to fight this people the
rest of my life you know I just and I
can't continue a lie he said if you do
that digger your life sentence I was
like sentence for what and then he
talked about it in the indictment said
but Alan I walked away eight months
before the the minimum mandatory laws
were enacted you know was when I when I
walked away from the cartel the most
they could give me was fifteen years
like they did the first time conspiracy
right fifteen years but now that law has
changed and that fifteen years became a
but three license a license a conspiracy
to import that you didn't important
conspiracy to possess while you were
going to import conspiracy to distribute
what you were gonna possess that you
were gonna import that's the law of the
land
Wow so I mean who can win that's crazy I
saw I'm like I'm gonna put it back I
said I say forget all I said I'll use
[ __ ]
I said I'm dead anyway if I die no
Street but my life we got changing my
life doesn't change I couldn't care I
don't care I don't care about living
anymore and I go in front of the
prosecutor and while my attorney agrees
look he's gonna confess to dealing but
really what the motion should give him
is violates your parole because I went
back while I was there all right I got
15 years the first time the most you
could do is five if you never had a
prior offense and then you I had ten
years on the pro so here I am gonna
confess that I violated the parole right
no wiretaps
not a single frickin picture not on a
grain of cocaine nothing in both trials
nothing and not a compromise picture
with anybody right I mean I took care of
myself
[Laughter]